une exposition de tableaux de grands
maîtres entièrement construit en briques
lego c'est l'exposition qui est
actuellement proposée au château chan
aurier à croissy sur seine
c'est une exposition sur les tableaux de
maîtres voilà donc c'est vraiment une
exposition où les gens vont pouvoir
s'asseoir étudier des tableaux et
regarder les tableaux comme dans un vrai
musée quoi sur place pas de surprise la
plupart des oeuvres présentées sont des
tableaux bien connu alors dans cette
exposition vous avez une trentaine de
tableaux donc en bas vous avez plus le
classique l'impressionnisme bien sûr
puisqu'on est à croissy vous allez
retrouver le tableau de renoir est au
dessus à l'étagé du dessus vous allez
retrouver un petit peu plus de modernité
avec le pop art notamment et andy warhol
toutes les oeuvres ont été réalisées à
croissy l'exposition a représenté 1200
heures de travail et sept cent quarante
mille briques à côté de chaque toile
vous avez un cartel qui explique
l'oeuvre et le nombre de briques lego
utilisé pour l'oeuvre
et puis le temps passé pour la montée un
parcours de jeu est prévu pour les
enfants exposition est proposée jusqu'au
18 juillet mais attention la réservation
est obligatoire pour pouvoir venir
visiter